so rudy giuliani is not having a
particularly good week first he claimed
that he was almost killed at a uh
grocery store then the surveillance
video came out and someone patted him on
the back he claimed that he was hit so
hard that the person standing next to
him almost fell down and then the video
came out and all of it was untrue so
that was not a great start to the week
for rudy giuliani
then cassidy hutchinson testified that
rudy giuliani wanted a pardon from
donald trump around the time of the
january 6th riots and rudy giuliani
accidentally admitted to that request
and i'm gonna show you the message he
subsequently deleted the tweet so let's
go piece by piece first and foremost
here is cassidy hutchinson on tuesday
saying rudy giuliani and mark meadows
they both wanted pardons related to
january 6th did rudy giuliani ever
suggest that he was interested in
receiving a presidential pardon related
to january 6th
he did
ms hutchison
did white house chief of staff mark
meadows ever indicate that he was
interested in receiving a presidential
pardon related to january 6th
mr meadows did seek that pardon yes so
very very clear rudy wanted a pardon and
mark meadows wanted a pardon okay fine
so tuesday night rudy giuliani tweets
once again the january 6th committee of
russian collusion liars suborned perjury
from cassidy hutchinson i specifically
told president trump i did not need want
or need a pardon
i also have witnesses to corroborate
that she and the committee are
perpetrating yet another lie okay
and then on wednesday
rudy doubled down
but he unfortunately admits to the
entire thing
rudy tweets the january 6th witch hunt
cabal has now exceeded even its prior
fraudulent
the
strange grammar okay the last witness
was a reckless liar
contrary to her false testimony she was
never present when i asked for a pardon
uh
did uh
she says that you slapped your wife sir
she was not there when i slapped my wife
i mean
i mean i didn't slap my wife
then rudy says actually i told the
president i did not want or need one he
then subsequently
deleted that tweet
uh not going particularly well for rudy
giuliani now one explanation would be
he's just confused what he meant by she
wasn't there when i asked for a pardon
is he never asked for a pardon maybe
that's actually what he meant but it
doesn't look particularly good when you
say she wasn't there when i did the
things she accuses me of doing and then
you delete the tweet all very very
strange and again
put the people under oath get rudy there
and have him testify under oath get
everybody there and have them contradict
her claims under oath i don't for a
second listen
when you're asked about things
from a year and a half ago you are
stressed now when you're being asked the
questions it was a stressful time then
i am completely sympathetic to the
notion
that there will be details that could be
off in this testimony i think that
applies to the friendly witnesses i
think that applies to the hostile
witnesses i think that that's perfectly
plausible
but right now
we have the under oath testimony of a
very composed cassidy hutchinson
and then we have the confusing and
contradictory
and sometimes bizarre admissions and
subsequent deletions
reacting to her claims put these people
under oath and we will evaluate their
claims with all of the same
consideration and seriousness that we're
evaluating the claims made by cassidy
hutchinson period